here is a reference so geeky that it
might even allude some reason TV viewers
i am nick gillespie with reason TV and
today i'm talking to glenn reynolds the
instapundit and the main man behind
pajamas media TV glenn thanks for coming
thanks for having me let the main man I
the you are the anchor and I mean that
in a good way not in a Walter Cronkite
kind of like holding us below water
until we drown kind of way talk
instapundit is one of the if not the
most successful aggregator site for a
broad-based kind of center-right
conservative libertarian world what is
the guiding principle behind the filter
at that instant in suppose built around
my own browsing habits basically I
assume that most people who are reading
my side are people who are already at
the computer for some other reason
typically work they're bored there or
they're procrastinating and they're
going to take a five-minute break they
go to instapundit they see what's new
maybe they follow a link or two then
they go back to whatever they were doing
and repeat as needed throughout your day
to keep your brain fresh what are your
three primary interests that kind of
varies in there there's always a threat
of sort of what's in the news at the
moment and I usually try to find
something about it that's not just what
everybody else is talking about if I can
the second is my own personal hobby
horses which are things like
nanotechnology red light cameras you
know SWAT team misbehavior you know
stuff like that which I put in whenever
I want and then the third is sort of
trying to find new and different stuff
that people haven't seen before or new
and different bloggers who you know
ought to have a bigger audience and so
it's just kind of mixed together how do
you define yourself ideologically I mean
you flirt with the phrase libertarian or
conservative how do you how do you
define I'm not conservative at all
really by you know other than you know
for a while support for the war in Iraq
was the litmus test for conservatism and
if that your lipids tasked sure but but
it's a dumb litmus test some people
describe you as a hind lining and
libertarian okay which is you know
somebody's strongly influenced by Robert
Heinlein and I think one thing in which
Highland did influence me is the sense
that he never expected very much out of
the political process and sort of one of
his recurring themes of his brand of
libertarianism was don't expect too much
from the political process the best
thing you can really hope for is to keep
it from being too crooked
and getting too much into your business
but the world is full of mrs. Grundy's
who live to interfere in your business
and you can never completely abolish
them you just have to keep fighting them
off how does that feed into your
interest in things a kind of
technological utopianism that is a
strain in your thought of nanotechnology
longevity I mean that's very hind lining
and in that you you keep the government
or you keep the powers that be at bay
but then you create your own world where
you can do what you want you know it
empowers people if you look at politics
it's actually very stagnant okay what's
cool in politics right now is 1968 right
we are we are the politics of 1968 are
the politics of 2009 right now in so
many ways uh you know no government
institution has actually gotten better
since nineteen sixty eight a very major
boy compare it to technology and you
know when you look back from the
standpoint of one hundred or a thousand
years from now that's what people will
think was the defining characteristic of
our age and it is the other thing is
most of these technologies have the
effect of making an individual more
powerful in relation to the state or
small group and here we are in the
reason TV studios right here previously
a TV show that not that long ago would
have been very expensive to produce and
distribute around the country in the
world and now isn't mean that's just one
example do you are we in a moment we're
kind of freedom and liberty and the
ability to innovate technologically and
even in a kind of lifestyle ways that
coming to an end or is that being
threatened or is it always blue skies I
think it's being threatened but I think
it's always being threatened you know
for Obama I mean my expectations I want
to wrote my small government
expectations for George Bush were were
quite modest and yet we're nonetheless
disappointed I didn't have any small
government expectations for Obama
particularly though I thought he would
be better on some of the sort of social
issues where I'm liberal and on those he
seems to actually be kind of socially
conservative of the absorption and gay
marriage and you know that sort of thing
and I suppose in a way that's not a
surprise but I was a little yeah so he
he's delivering nothing for me really I
mean he's he's you know a big spender
intrusive government kind of guy who's
also you know not supportive of gay
marriage or things that I do support so
how have worried
you about his health care reform plans
if they succeed I think that we will see
the curve of medical innovation which is
pretty steep right now really flattened
out why well you'll still have research
I think the government still funds
research and you'll still have people
discover things but the process of
turning those lab discoveries into a
pill that you can buy is right now done
by pharma companies who are supposed to
be evil and if the only person or entity
they can sell that pill to is the
government and if the government's main
goal is to spend as little money as
possible there's not much incentive to
progress so I think we're to see a lot
less medical innovation and paradox Lee
right at the time when we should be
seeing a whole lot more you know we're
part way through the singularity right
so what what a terrible time to turn off
the lights well that's right yeah that's
right talk about a pj TV I mean you
instapundit and pajamas media are allies
now we're business partners you have a
regular show on pj TV what is what's the
benefit of pj TV / pajamas media one
point out i have to say pj TV it's
always me living one of my geek
fantasies because i remember very much
and the late 90s sort of playing with a
video camera and hooking up to the
computer and doing stuff on the internet
and say you know we should be able to
pull all this stuff together and you
could have a TV network on the cheap and
you couldn't really quite do it then you
sort of could but but if you remember
the old real player with the smudgy
little images and all it didn't work
very well but it is you know now I mean
I've got an HD studio actually in my
basement with a green screen that you
can put virtual studios in and I can
interview people from all over the world
via skype or ichat or whatever and bring
him in and it all just you know it's
just cool and it's all dirt cheap
compared to a regular TV network you
have been accused and I think with some
justice of having a mad crush on Sarah
Palin what do you what yes at least in a
office chatter here but and in the pages
of the LA Times recently you
had a lot of good things to say about
Sarah Palin does she represent the
future of the Republican Party or should
we care about the future the room I mean
what I said the only times was actually
I found Sarah Palin a lot less
interesting than the sarah palin
phenomenon and he just hatred she
inspires and a lot of people my sense I
whether she's a future the Republican
Party is I don't know well let me here's
a reference so geeky that it might even
allude some reason TV viewers but I used
to play a war game when I was a kid
called Luftwaffe which was air combat in
World War two and when the Germans got
in trouble which they always did one of
the ways they could get more planes was
to call the cadets out of the training
fields and put them in the air and what
you did that they were never as good
they stayed at two instead of a three or
whatever it was for the rest of the game
well that's kind of what the Republicans
did to Sarah Palin the truth is she
wasn't ready for national politics she
has tremendous raw political talent I
mean the speech he gave at the RNC some
other stuff really shows that but she
just wasn't ready well you're a state or
a local political figure the media does
it create its own straw man version of
you and then attack it because they all
know you and everybody their readers
knowing they just can't get away with
that at the national level they do that
and they did that with her and they were
able to do it and she wasn't able to
respond some of that was the ineptitude
at the McCain campaign in general but
she just wasn't ready and I think that
the Republicans did themselves a
disservice by calling her up when they
did will she do better later I don't
know does it does if you're a
libertarian does the does your future
depend on the the renewed health or
vigor of the Republican Party or is it
something beyond that you know if you're
a libertarian neither party is all that
great but the Republicans are clearly
less bad and I think that there was a
time you know as recently as a year ago
when a lot of libertarians were telling
themselves that wasn't true that you
know you couldn't be any worse than the
Republicans and I think that we've seen
that yes you can what the Republicans
are going to do I don't know about that
I think if you look at what seems to
work for the Republicans taking a more
libertarian line really seems to work
for them so they obviously want to be
right I mean
about it really that does seem to be the
way they should be moving and the
interesting thing is that a lot of the
social conservatives are actually okay
on that there are the the percentage of
social conservatives who want their
beliefs enacted into law to force other
people to live like them is it sits
there but it's by no means the
overwhelming majority so you know you
don't have to pander in 1970s Jerry
Falwell style anymore and i think that
the Republicans need to figure that out
I want to thank glenn reynolds of
instapundit and of pj TV for talking to
reason TV today i'm nick gillespie